the las vegas strip will soon have
another property that promises to shine
brightly
yeah resorts world is still under
construction but it's already starting
its hiring process and we're talking a
lot of people
christian casadas joining us now live
along las vegas boulevard with details
about how you can score a job christian
well denise bryan the uh resorts world
is telling us that they're doing all
their hiring a virtual they've told me
that they have received over 90 000
applications so it's an
overwhelming number considering the fact
that they're only looking for
a few thousand to help run this property
that you see here behind me they tell me
that they're only looking
for about 6 000 people so you can
definitely get a sense of
the urgent need for jobs for those
numbers now i can tell you that eight
news now uh spoke to the president of
the property and he tells us that most
positions
like frontline workers will be hired 60
days before opening
like bartenders valet attendees and
dealers about 400 people have been hired
and currently working but that number
according to the property president
will grow to about 6 000 as opening day
gets closer
we asked about the grand opening and we
were only given a specific date
about the summer time with the systems
we have in place we're
constantly communicating with the
applicants so they always know where
they stand
we have it set up where they can do
their own video and they can really
showcase themselves
so we see their personality before we
even bring them on property and that's
been going very well
the feedback we get has been really
positive again
our challenge is how do we pick the best
6 000 employees
wool resorts world is located just south
of sahara and convention center drive
the 4.3 billion dollar hotel
will combine three hilton brands into a
3 500 room resort tower
and about 117 000 square feet of gaming
they promise new dining options
luxury shopping a state-of-the-art
theater and of course nightlife
also they have plans for what i'm told
will be an infinity pool with a
spectacular view
of the strip now back out here live a
big project as you can imagine
will need many employees to see its
daily operations
also you can see the 100 000 square foot
led screen
on the west portion of the tower right
there on your screen obviously a very
exciting time
for las vegas and also for many folks
who are looking to get back on their
feed and land a job
now if you're looking if you're
interested in getting one of these jobs
well all you have to do is just visit
our website eightnewsnow.com for all
that information
christian gossip is 8 news now